meanwhile fed up with the biden's board
of policies a high-level ice official
quitting his post after 30 years in an
email to hot colleagues says this
a now former ice enforcement and removal
operations officer writes
this quote from this letter to fight and
argue every day about not arresting or
releasing horrible criminal aliens to
the street
quite frankly is disgusting that's
something similar that tom holman has
said before retired acting ice director
himself
he received the email and is talking
about it tom your reaction to
your friend's move to leave
well first of all it's sad that someone
spends 30 years serving their nation
they're going out this way
they're going out and not be able to do
their job i know this man is a friend of
mine and he's a patriot served this
nation for over 30 years
but he's quitting because he runs a
large field office he's
he's a senior level official runs a
large field off she has several hundred
agents working for him
and he can't let his agents do their job
because he's under orders not to rest
they can't arrest illegal aliens anymore
brian you can be in the country
illegally go to court an immigration
judge
ordered you removed and ice can't touch
them and remove them
and and the criminals if you're if
you're convicted of assault they can't
they can't arrest you they had a case a
guy was convicted of dui
four times four times he was ordered
removed by an immigration judge
when he got out of jail ice how to drop
the detainer because he's no longer a
priority
you gotta be convicted of a serious
serious crime or ice can't touch you
you can't enforce the immigration law
anymore under by administration
this guy cannot look his agents in the
eye every day and keep saying no to them
you can't do your job you can't uphold
your oath so he said it he quit
now tell you something there's 24 field
office directors across the nation
i've talked to almost all of them they
would all quit today
if they could but they got mortgages
they got children in college they're all
miserable
the morale ice is destroyed this agency
is not the same age it ever has been
before this has never been a party
problem we all agree
on to the arrest uh criminals in our
midst when you cross the border you
broke the law
it was never a party problem now
democrats say come one come all and
republicans say
are you insane since when does that work
in our country's best interest but don't
worry
the vice president's on the job and she
outlined her priorities
and it's all about other countries let's
look at this together tom
number one address economic inequality
because you know we have to settle on
inequality when it comes to central and
south america advancing the rule of law
we've got to make sure that they are
doing a good job advancing the rule of
law
promoting respect for respect for human
rights oh goody so we'll focus on
guatemala and el salvador not here in
america
counting or preventing crime combating
sexual gender-based and domestic
violence see if we handle all these
things
that'll really help things at the border
do you think so
no it's like that's a joke in six months
what have they done
they've done two things they wrote 11
page memo it means nothing
because number one in that memo should
have been secure the border
and allow immigration agents to do their
job and arrest criminals
and number two the only thing they've
done successfully brian is you're
getting really good at releasing people
quickly
president biden said last week when she
was asked by the cnn town hall how about
the immigration issue oh we got to solve
because
people used to be in border patrol
customs we got it down 90 why
because you release them quickly they
call that a success i call that
enticement people around the world are
watching saying okay
now i'm getting united states i'm going
to be released quickly and they're going
to bust me
out send a plane and get me to my final
destination
they follow our news more than we follow
our news so
yesterday uh a
biden official was asked what are you
doing at the border you're so concerned
about the pandemic and the surgeon who's
vaccinated here
at the border these people are coming in
without any vaccines
we don't know who's testing positive and
who's not listen to this exchange
why is it that the federal government is
asking vaccinated americans to wear
masks
to stop the spread of coba 19 but at the
same time federal agents are also
releasing covet 19 positive border
processors into small towns in texas
cbp provides migrant with ppe from the
moment from the moment they are taken
into custody and migrants are required
to keep masks
on at all times wow hey migrant i know
you're here illegally and you've broken
many many laws but keep that mask on is
that the way it's being done
at the border no what they should ask
her is is cbp testing for cobait upon
arrest
are you allowing an illegal alien to
leave a border trail station or the line
without being tested to cbp themselves
to the federal government test the
answer is no
they're counting on the local
communities to test them they'll get
into a hotel room
and then maybe test them at a hotel room
to do an ngo and they get covered guess
what
it's too late he's in the hotel room
with 300 people and and they're going to
get him on a bus i'm getting on a plane
and look you know they gave a master
brian they give a match to 166 000
people they released without a court
date
they give a mass to i got 8 400
criminals they've arrested they given
mass to criminals they've arrested 49 of
them who was convicted
of homicide that they came across the
border 274 gang members
the bottom line is this administration
is is holding americans to a different
standard
and they're holding illegal aliens
they're they're purposely releasing
illegal aliens into the country with no
court date and with coven
it doesn't make sense it's a magnet for
more to come
and yesterday caught off mike joe biden
we're in this reconciliation package
we're going to put in immigration reform
and try to naturalize
8 million illegals that's a go sign to
central and south america
to haiti the caribbean everywhere around
the world come one
come all illegally look out and the
border patrol is in the line of fire
with no support
tom holman thanks so much
you got it thank you thank you very much
you're right on target